bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je suis à
ubisoft on va me présenter un jeu vidéo
que je vais avoir la chance de pouvoir
doubler avec ma bouche
j'ai juste trop hâte c'est parti ton
personnage sur youtube hypersportif
super enthousiaste qui gueule tout en
termes les gens la petite d'inde ce
petit personnage s'appelle lévis et
c'est celui que je double il faut savoir
qu'il a 16 ans bon bah écoute ils ont
choisi quelqu'un de mature pour le pour
le rôle mais ça m'a tout de suite
par contre frappé norman maintenant
c'est la vie
et voilà
et tu as l'air cool tu veux rejoindre
notre équipe on sait pas ce qui nous
attend
je vais te dire un truc qui s'y trouvent
une réunion de robots super méchant
[Musique]
c'est trop cool mec on a eu beau portail
n pour nous donner bon ça va être du
temps seulement [ __ ] c'est toi à mes
ouais ce crash était carrément pété quoi
allez lâchez pas si tu as vu mais j'ai
genre tout défoncer bonjour particules
très très peu embauché moi non mais
c'est essayer de prendre ton temps un
peu plus sur le tout ça va être en trop
bien bienvenue dans l'équipe bien joué
qu'est ce que tu as envie hein as
mathiot alors tout va bien c'est très
sympa à faire le problème c'est que
j'arrête pas de saturer ma voix parce
que je la criée et porter la voix et du
coup je en train de me l'a défoncé
rihanna va m'annoncer le chiffre le
nombre que par ce que j'ai à dire en
tout il n'a pas voulu me vient c'est à
présent 13 223 me mets à temps mais on
s'en fout puisque ont fait l'un des plus
beaux métiers du monde la
comédie-française liesse passe par un de
ses amis un métier du monde à l'action
mais je réagis à mon arme je me demande
ce qui se passerait si j'en essayer une
autre
le mec il dit vraiment on goût il faut
que tu te dire avec ta manette peu sur
son point faible maintenant mieux j'en
fais des caisses quand je parle je parle
en bas et je m'entends elle est où cette
tempête j'ai trop envie de foncer dedans
là c'est qui le patron c'est les villes
patron je vais qu'il fait est fait j'ai
plus de voix j'ai juste trop mal aux
cordes vocales qu'on y est
en fin de journée première fois que
j'enregistre de l'animation et pour ma
super expérience
j'ai juste hâte de faire la deuxième
journée qui est dans quelques jours
d'ici là je vais prendre pas mal de miel
là l'équipe d'ubisoft va me présenter le
jeu en avant première ces particules en
fait c'est pas qu'un simple jeu vidéo tu
rajoute aussi des petits jouets sur la
manette et quand je fais le déjouer
modulaire ou quand tu plug le vaisseau
sur la manette ça se répercute
directement génial on se repasse à son
petit rail est donc un jeu plus aucune
arme va directement se répercuter dans
le jeu aille dire et donc ça c'est mon
personnage s'appelle évite comme marie
yes marchelli donc toi tu te casses
tu laisse place aux kings donc à tous
ces caissons peut jouer avec tout ça
reste l'un des plus puissants s'il a été
construit il ya un moteur v6 en fait et
bien fait pas mieux donc tu connais un
petit peu et l'association ac on a ça
plus basé sur un moteur tesla c'est à
dire qu'ils marchent à l'énergie
renouvelable
bon c'est plus un vaisseau de davos a
pas se mentir et donc lui c'est le
vaisseau nadir un donc moins peu plus
oriental qui donc a investi et qui
explique que de la fumée de deux chiche
à la blague raciste
merci à l'est non mais non à pretoria un
petit quelque chose pour toi au nom là
tu sais le pull de lévis quoi en tout
cas deuxième journée d'enregistrement en
studio cette fois ci encore plus que
d'habitude la patate
on a beaucoup de phrases a enregistré
sans plus attendre on part en cabine et
aujourd'hui on va voir si ma voix s'en
porte mieux la lolilol îlots lui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'atlas
waouh je vais faire un max de vue avec
master est hors de question lévy
personne n'est censé être au courant il
est temps que ça change
mais tu délires c'est bien c'est bien
parfait en fait c'est juste un gros
ballon peter quoi merci madame
il a le nez dans un homme qui a mauvaise
haleine pendant tout l'après midi
après l'inde où il a dit petit pote
devrait déjà nous suffire pour décoller
ouais vous pour être valorisées
totalement on est avec sky art qui est
aussi un geste on a d'ailleurs perdu bac
pro gamer septembre ressemble beaucoup
de basques alerte attention yo je suis
l'ami mcrae et je viens massacrer la
région est ce que je peux faire quelque
chose pour rendre utile
merci et bravo parfait bien joué [ __ ]
de merde
mesdames et messieurs nous enregistrons
le dernier fichier bon globalement on a
enregistré 500 phrase pour ce jeu et là
on est sur la toute dernière phrase qui
est plutôt un cri c'est un cri de chute
ok on prépare le miel et la tisane
yes on a fini c'est puis juste trop bien
à bout du monde c'est vrai
le jour on a réussi à combattre à galaxy
je suis très content de cette expérience
de doublage pas évident mais voilà j'ai
appris plein de trucs ça a été très
enrichissant le personnage de lévis
vraiment je le kiffe parce qu'il est
vraiment haut en couleurs jeudi a eu la
chance de doubler le personnage
principal du film projet x et quelques
années c'était génial aussi sur un film
plus classique faut vraiment suivre ce
qu'a fait déjà le personnage marché dans
son sillon et coller à toutes ces
onomatopées alors que dans un film
d'animation où dans un jeu vidéo
la liberté de création est beaucoup plus
en plus on peut se permettre de faire
plus d'un pro plus de montagnes russes
et de se lâcher en fait ça c'est très
cool du coup juste moi je kiffe j'ai
pris du plaisir à faire ça et j'espère
que vous avez pris un petit peu plaisir
aussi à regarder cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à mettre un petit à petit de tap
je vous laisse là dessus et moi je
retourne dans mon vaisseau parce que
j'ai un maximum de sa squid à exterminer
afin de sauver la galaxie lévy macrez
démarche
[Musique]